okay everybody so i am really
really excited to talk about this
episode of wanda vision this is episode
8
previously on so we've really hit the
pen ultimate episode here which is
always exciting in a show especially in
season one because
you get a lot of information to set up
what's going to come
in a finale so with one division it's
interesting because
it's gonna fall into this trap where i
don't even
think marvel expected so many people to
take the show like a west world
and have all these theories online and
people breaking down
every little thing and having now their
hopes up for certain reveals so
i'm worried that maybe there's gonna be
a deflated feeling people have
even watching this episode that they
maybe didn't get
certain villains appear like a mephisto
or magneto
but i also have a feeling that
after watching this episode that we
might be
doing more than one season of wanda
vision maybe not called juana vision but
wanda's story
and that they're setting up more
villains or just
places to go even if it's just solely to
set up maybe the villain for the doctor
strange
movie that she will be in but
there's a lot of things i thought were
great about this episode
i on first reaction love that it opened
with agatha harkness and that
we got a little bit of an origin story
for her and that she had her little
mommy issues
and she ends up killing all these
witches around her
including her own mother uh and that was
really
intense and this obviously was a
spotlight episode for katherine han
she's been killing it but now she gets
to really
play the villain here where she was
playing a villain in disguise in the
past
now she kind of shows her chops here
which was excellent
a standout line that literally just came
in the beginning was
that accent really comes and goes she
says to
wanda which i love they always play on
themselves and joke around
with characters in the mcu and this
really worked here and
you got hooked in right away just being
in that basement with
wanda and agnes
or should i say agatha and what's
interesting is they took the route
of anything like a christmas carol story
right where
agatha's now bringing wanda through the
past and now we're actually getting a
true
wanda origin story now what's smart
about this and made me excited about the
mcu doing
shows now is that we can really go into
origin stories for characters we've
known that didn't really get one
in a movie and you're also gonna get
payoff now that you can't get in a
marvel movie with super
emotional character beats and that
happens a lot in this episode
and really it every flashback counts
here of wanda i mean
just them showing that shell that came
from stark
that ended up being the reason her
parents died was crazy to actually
visually see and it hit more and i love
how they connected
that in that moment she was watching a
sitcom as like
something to attach to and protect her
and that she grew up around this and it
makes so much sense
to why she would create the sitcom world
in the show
we see so i really like that i love
also the actors who played the kids of
pietro and wanda i thought they were
great
and then we go to this other flashback
here where we see wanda actually
is confronted by the mind stone and i
love this flash we get of like
her legitly in the scarlet witch outfit
i thought that was crazy and i
really want to know more theories you
guys have about that and kind of can
explain
why she would see that vision and what
that could mean for the future for her
character i'd love to hear your thoughts
on that
but it's really interesting because
they're also kind of
delving into this confusion about the
character of
wanda or you say scarlet witch in the
mcu compared to
her being like oh is she magneto's
daughter from that version
is she a mutant but they kind of combine
it where she was a
baby witch like agatha says
and then also then adapted even more
powers
through her main powerful streak as a
superhero of this
mind stone and it's crazy how they
brilliantly connected it with vision and
how
she would have that power then when she
creates
the world at the end and creates the
sitcom place she brings to life vision
literally giving birth to
a illusion of vision because of that
connection she had to the mind stone
which was obviously
envision's head and where she got her
powers from
now that's where it was really hit
home well where you had this flashback
of
wanda with vision and this is right
after the ultron events after ultron
killed pietro and you see that he
comfort her during her grief
and agatha hits on that like well you
know now that vision's gone
you didn't have anyone to comfort you
there like there wasn't vision to
comfort you for losing vision
and it really showed that weakness and
why
wanda would break there and i thought
with that flashback
there was that really good line that
stood out where he
says what is grief if not love
persevering so you're really hitting on
the theme of the whole
show now because we're getting towards
the end and it's now
wanda waking up by the end of this
episode and
it's funny because what's ironic about
what agatha was doing
here is agatha admires wanda as a witch
it's like how are you doing all these
powers like this is
crazy because i do crazy stuff but you
just created this whole
world she's like a fan of her in a sense
and wants to know
how it all happened but in her doing
that she's actually helping wanda
because she's getting wanted to face now
her traumas and actually work through
them and
it's ironic too because she even has a
line agatha where she says only
way forward is back which is so untrue
it's just the opposite of the saying
only way forward is through
but what's really good about wanda here
she's actually going through it now
she's not
ignoring it and is kind of getting that
character growth we need for her to
set up in the finale to be the hero we
know of wanda and to set up this
big moment where they actually say her
name is scarlet witch for the first time
in the mcu
and that she's this chaos magic and what
was really
well well well first off there's a
post-credits scene so please if you
haven't seen it it's a big one so i'm
going to talk about in a second but this
is your warning to go watch it first and
come back
but it's interesting because it's
connected to hayward right and how
we get this moment we're waiting for the
time of like okay what happened after
end game
with wanda and where did she go how did
she handle the vision thing and
we get to see it and it was haunting
just seeing visions body parts
on this table here that hayward had and
hayward planted the idea in her head
to like yeah you can bring vision back
because it's all for him it's all for
his greed and wanting
vision himself and he knew he needed
wanda there so it really is this
mastermind plan by
hayward and what you see in the
post-credits scene is that
coming to life for him and he's getting
what he wants is that
okay great i got something with wanda's
power on it i'm using it and he's
actually taking the real vision
body and bringing him back to life in
some kind of form which is the
post-credits scene which was just
crazy so we're going to see that come
out next week which i think is going to
be the big
reveal of like what's really going on
with this new version of vision
but i really loved agatha in this
episode and of course
obviously elizabeth olsen just kills it
per usual but catherine han really stood
out here she did amazing and i thought
it was so cool
seeing agatha harkness now at the end in
her full witch form
holding the kids and they had that
really just amazing makeup on her
costume design is just awesome and it's
also interesting because i do think
they're setting up
because agatha's a fellow witch and she
was kind of giving her you know wanda a
little bit of witch school in this
episode
that from the comics being that she's
like a mentor and teaches her a lot of
it i think they are kind of pushing her
where she's first
a villain but might become more of a
great character and actually
be someone that actually maybe teams up
with wanda in the future of her story
we'll see
but i thought this episode was
excellent i think that it
obviously was heavy on the flashback
here but it was necessary because
it gave the origin story of wanda here
that we wanted
it also gave an order story of hackathon
they did in one episode
and i think it's setting up a really
exciting finale
now i'm going to address so that i think
my personal bias and i think a lot of
fans will have this and this is
what we do in this new time of watching
tvs like i said about reddit and
everyone with the theories
it's like okay am i disappointed there's
no mephisto magneto at the moment
yes but i have to take a step back and
realize i still got this really cool
villain in agatha harkness and all these
stories are getting payoffs and earned
here so
it's hard to just like say oh it did bad
because it didn't
like succeed in making our theories
correct that maybe have been more
exciting
it's tough it's a tall task to pull off
and i think a lot of shows are
struggling with that at the moment
because it's like they're paying
like for a crime they didn't even commit
and it's like
something good for them where they got
everyone all talking about the show it's
the water cooler talk week to week show
but
you know then you pay the price for
because people really want one of these
crazy things to come true and
some of these videos like i said screen
crush just nails it they've called so
much they called how wanda was gonna
have
the sitcom stuff she watched as a kid
and that would influence her
it's like beat by beat so you got to
also be careful too how much you watch
online
uh with theories and stuff because it
can kind of in a way somehow spoil it
because usually
a lot of people are getting it right now
so you could feel deflated when the
reveals come but
overall looking at it as a penultimate
episode in the season i'm gonna give it
a 9.2
i thought it was really well done and
again
i like they went with the christmas
carol style with agatha
walking wanda through her past and that
she's not even realizing at the villain
that she's actually helping wanda now
kind of break through her trauma while
just again so greedy and wanting to just
find out
how is wanda pulling all this off it was
cool to have agatha like a
very worthy flow to wanda's powers and
they're kind of just bringing in the
whole witch thing and embracing that
which i think is awesome and it's fresh
for the mcu
and yeah i'm of course so excited for
the finale and i appreciate this is a
longer episode than god and i'm sure the
finale is going to be
long as well let me know what you
thought is down below i love to hear
your thoughts i read every comment try
to respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe i'll be
reviewing every episode of monovision
you don't want to miss those
i'm also doing a show servant i do
celebrity interviews and movies so
you're going to check that out
as well and please follow me at steve
all the show on twitter instagram for
more of me
and i'll see you next time